en el vídeo acerca de la estructura
molecular del adn vimos que estaba
compuesto por dos hebras en las cuales
la columna vertebral de cada hebra está
compuesta por un grupo fosfato y después
un azúcar ok se está alternando entre un
grupo fosfato y un azúcar y luego otro
grupo fosfato de hecho podríamos
dibujarla por acá primero tenemos un
grupo fosfato y luego tenemos un azúcar
y luego otro grupo fosfato y de una vez
voy a dibujar el otro grupo fosfato y
enmedio alternándose tenemos un azúcar y
como podemos ver pasa exactamente lo
mismo en la otra hebra de adn donde
empezamos con un grupo fosfato luego
tenemos un azúcar luego otro grupo
fosfato y otro azúcar y otro grupo
fosfato tenemos aquí un azúcar y un
grupo fosfato y otro azúcar así es que
la otra hebra también se va a ver así
ok primero voy a dibujar
los grupos fosfatos y en medio tenemos
los azúcares y lo que une a estas dos
hebras que de hecho podemos pensarlas
como los peldaños de una escalera lo que
une a estas dos son las bases
nitrogenadas complementarias y la razón
por las que les llamamos bases
nitrogenadas que por cierto se me olvidó
hablar de esto en el vídeo pasado es
porque estos nitrógeno son muy electro
negativos y de hecho se podrían quedar
con más protones de hidrógeno estos
nitrógeno tienen un par de electrones
libres más que en las condiciones
adecuadas pueden utilizar para absorber
más protones de hidrógeno y ahora muchas
personas en este momento se empiezan a
preguntar oye por qué es que el adn
tiene esta parte de ácido en su nombre
si están estos nitrógenos dispuestos a
absorber protones y porque decimos que
el adn es ácido bueno lo que sucede es
que aquí estamos utilizando y
compensando la propiedad de base de los
nitrógeno a la hora de formar estos
de hidrógeno los cuales son los que
están manteniendo unidas a estas bases
nitrogenadas complementarias formando
estos peldaños en esta escalera pero
además la razón por la que decimos que
es un ácido es porque aquí los grupos
fosfatos cuando están protón a dos son
ácidos y la razón por la que solemos
dibujarlos des protón a dos es porque
son tan ácidos que si los colocamos en
una solución neutra pierden sus protones
en sí es que casi siempre que los vas a
encontrar de esta forma en el interior
del núcleo de una célula generalmente te
los vas a encontrar des protón a dos
pero en general los grupos fosfatos son
considerados ácidos si estuviera yo
hablando acerca de un grupo fosfato en
su estado más puro dibujaría yo por aquí
un hidrógeno y de hecho ya hablamos de
eso en el vídeo acerca de la estructura
del adn ok y también borraría esta carga
negativa de aquí pero bueno este es una
especie de repaso del vídeo anterior
claro que como ya empecé aquí hacer
algunas abstracciones pues vamos
y con esto por aquí tengo yo a la base
nitrogenada terminé de color verde
así es que esto está enlazado con una
timina y la base nitrogenada
complementaria de la timina es la
adenina ok que estoy aquí y circulando
de color naranja
esta es la benigna adenina y por aquí
podemos ver estos dos puentes de
hidrógeno en los cuales tenemos cargas
parciales positivas y cargas parciales
negativas en los dos extremos del puente
de hidrógeno y que se sienten muy
atraídas y después vamos al siguiente
escalón al siguiente peldaño de la
escalera y que es lo que está pasando
por acá bueno pues esta base nitrogenada
es la citosina citó cine y está enlazada
con buen in a esta base nitrogenada es
la guanina guanina y de hecho también
vimos esto en el vídeo de la
introducción al adn y ahora tal vez
ahorita podrías decir oye estas dos
cebras se ven como que paralelas la una
a la otra no y en cierto sentido eso es
cierto pero hay un detalle muy
interesante del cual tal vez ya te diste
cuenta y ese detalle es la orientación
de estas hebras y en verdad eso de
orientación es la mejor forma de
describir lo que está pasando pero se
puede notar especialmente cuando nos
fijamos en estos azúcares así es que
observa atentamente estas
desoxirribonucleico bueno al menos estos
azúcares del adn derivados de las
mientras que si nos fijamos del lado
derecho los oxígenos de los anillos
están hacia abajo
así es que están en orientaciones
diferentes aquí el oxígeno está
apuntando hacia arriba y aquí el oxígeno
está apuntando hacia abajo y bueno para
hacer mucho más concretos lo que podemos
hacer es utilizar la numeración de estos
carbonos y utilizarla para pensar en la
orientación de estas moléculas para
pensar en la dirección y así tener una
forma concreta de describir estas dos
direcciones las 10 que pues vamos a
enumerar nuestros carbonos este azúcar
proviene de la ribosa aquí tenemos estas
dos moléculas de ribosa como vimos en el
vídeo acerca de la estructura del adn
pero aquí en el adn estamos hablando de
la desoxirribonucleico dro geno ok por
aquí no tenemos este grupo hidroxilo y
en
tenemos un hidrógeno pero bueno vamos a
enumerar estos carbonos y cuando estamos
numerando aquí siempre empezamos por el
carbono del grupo carbón y lo entonces
este es el carbono 1 prima carbono
2 primer 3 prima 4 prima y 5 primer
simplemente los número y luego cuando
estamos viendo a la desoxirribonucleico
este es el carbono 1 prima carbono 1 1er
este es el carbono 2 primer 3 primer 4
primer y 5 prima y ahora si quisiéramos
numerar estos carbonos pero ya aquí en
este diagrama del adn pues este es el
carbono 1 1er
este es el carbono 2 1er este es el
carbono 3 primer el carbono 4 primer y
el carbono 5 prima entonces tenemos
estos grupos post patos enlazados
utilizando estos enlaces fósforo
estévez qué es lo que permite que se
mantenga unida a esta columna vertebral
pero el punto es que estamos yendo de
fosfato al carbono 5 primero y luego a
través del azúcar estamos viendo al
carbono 3 primero de ahí nos vamos a
otro grupo fosfato y de ahí a un carbono
5 primer pasando por la molécula de
azúcar al carbono 3 prima y a otro grupo
fosfato y estos dos números de aquí los
sacamos simplemente de la numeración de
estos carbonos que se empiezan a numerar
a partir del carbono que se encuentra en
el grupo carbón y lo de la molécula en
su forma de cadena lineal pero podemos
ver que aquí en esta línea tenemos
fosfato 5 prima 3 prima fosfato 5
primates primera fosfato
así es que una forma de describir a esta
dirección es decir que estamos yendo de
5 prima a 3 primero podemos poner por
aquí que estamos viendo de 5 primero a 3
primero
izquierdo pero qué es lo que estamos
haciendo del lado derecho bueno pues
vamos a enumerar los carbonos de este
lado también este es el carbono 1 primer
porque esta molécula está invertida con
respecto a esta y luego éste es el
carbono 2 primer carbono 3 primer 4
prima y 5 prima y también los podemos
numerar por aquí este es el carbono 1
prime 2 prime 3 primer 4 primer y 5
primero y entonces tenemos fosfato 3
prima 5 primera fosfato 3 prima 5 prima
y fosfato así es que la forma en la que
estos azúcares están orientados si vamos
de arriba hacia abajo están orientados
de tal forma que vamos de tres primeras
cinco prima aunque hay del lado derecho
estamos viendo de tres primero a cinco
prima y si queremos poner una flecha de
cinco primera tres primer le tenemos que
poner así
si es que podríamos decir que estas dos
son paralelas pero como están yendo en
direcciones opuestas está estructura del
adn aunque sean paralelas vamos a decir
que son anti paralelas así es que esta
es la estructura anti paralela del adn y
estas dos cebras son complementarias
están definidas la una por la otra la
timina se enlaza con la adenina la
citosina se enlaza con la guanina o
bueno se atraen mutuamente a través de
estos enlaces de hidrógeno pero estas
dos columnas vertebrales apuntan en
direcciones opuestas y otra cosa muy
interesante que hay que pensar cuando
estamos hablando acerca de la estructura
molecular del adn es cómo se forma esta
estructura como saben todas estas cosas
como orientarse y bueno algo que juega
un papel muy importante es el hecho de
que estos fosfatos tengan esta carga
negativa y todos los átomos que tienen
una carga negativa intentan lo mejor que
pueden alejarse los unos de otros y por
lo tanto como se están tratando de
alejar mutuamente terminan orientados de
esta forma y bueno además estas
moléculas son muy largas realmente muy
muy muy largas hemos hablado un poco de
eso en el vídeo de introducción al adn
incluso hablamos de los largos que son
los cromosomas y hablamos de cuántos
pares de bases tienen y cómo podemos
recordar realmente son muy grandes y
estos fosfatos quieren alejarse
mutuamente y por otro lado estas bases
nitrogenadas quieren estar lo más cerca
posible que se sienten muy atraídos
mutuamente y forman estos enlaces de
hidrógeno así es que todo eso junto es
lo que forma esta estructura de adn así
es que la molécula de adn es una
molécula fascinante podríamos hablar de
ella día y noche por mucho tiempo y es
realmente impactante las implicaciones
que tienen en quiénes somos cada uno de
nosotros pero bueno espero que este
vídeo te haya
un poco de emoción acerca de
molecularmente que es el adn